you've talked about it you've written
about it
so i hope it's okay for me to say that
your sister your older sister
on may 31st 1964
was raped and murdered by a local boy
so the echoes of pain and anger from
that tragic day
do they ripple through your life still
through your wrestling through your
coaching through your the way you
when you wake up in the morning what is
that like
it can be very emotional to me under
certain circumstances
and it can be
the mood i'm in right you know it can be
maybe if i've had a mountain dew or or
maybe if i've had a gable beer
yeah or or or uh
or maybe if you turn the country music
up a little bit loud
you know it emotions come out and
everybody has them in their life
it just so happens you know what brings
it out
and hopefully it's nothing that you do
to the extreme
point of to where it brings it out for
me it's not extreme
i don't have to have any of that really
i can get emotional
how did that change you as a man what it
did was
realize that i was already
pretty well developed because i was only
a sophomore
15 years old in high school and
i had parents that weren't making it and
my parents are a lot older than me
and now that we're down just to me and
my parents
and i'm going to be around the house for
another two years
and they had just lost a daughter that
was the only
only other sibling
they weren't handling it they they were
the ones that were
suffering much more than me
even though i always look back upon one
area
that i wasn't good at was communication
at that time except inside the wrestling
room
because i had been tipped off and tipped
off what do you mean
well the neighborhood said that
something to me about my sister
just three weeks before that that's
right that really
wasn't normal or practical
and i said nothing to nobody you
you don't is there a part of you that
blames yourself
yeah absolutely
absolutely but i'm 15 years old
and you make mistakes
uh and you don't really act on
everything
that happens in your life but i can tell
you how it affected me and
i acted a lot on anything that maybe
wasn't even of that consequence
i mean because i had four daughters and
i'm telling you when they left every
time to go somewhere in a car or go out
with some place
i always said something to them and they
would always say dad you said that last
night
i don't care what like i love you or
like i'd be careful i'd stay like don't
be driving and drinking or or don't be
uh
in a car with somebody that's uh you
know of of the
of the same nature or you know stay out
of trouble you know don't go be
somewhere where you
you know you have i said you know how to
get out of a car if you if your car goes
into the river
you know you know i just you know i'm
always thinking ahead a little bit
just in case if something uh did happen
and i it goes back to that it goes back
to that walk to school with that
with that young man that when he was
talking to me and i just
i took it and i kept it inside me and
once i found out she had been murdered
it
it took me maybe 25 to 30 minutes
and i told my dad i think i know who
killed her
and he looked at me and he just like
he slapped me actually he pushed me
against the car he didn't slam he pushed
me in his car my mom
slaps me and she was the one that
slapped me around a little bit but my
dad
he uh he he pushed me against his car
what do you mean you might know
something about this
i said that i i don't for sure but
and i would probably all crying but and
i don't i doubt if i was crying
yet i've probably cried a lot of tears
since but
but you know i just said hey i was
walking to school
with this neighbor and i never had
walked to school with him before
and he was kind of a troubled kid
and he said something about diane
and it wasn't good but i
i didn't he goes why didn't you say
something i said i daddy
i i just boy talk you know so you know
and so he hugged he hugged me he hugged
me he hugged me
and uh you know it was one of these
things that
it's definitely made me
a lot of who i am because there's been a
lot of choices
and i don't i took the word choice out
of my life and i just like to say okay
do the right thing
do the thing that's that you should do
and so i don't really i don't it's like
you're going to do this or this
well what do you mean which one's better
you know well then i'm
so i don't have that choice yeah just
give me the right way to go
and so not that i've been perfect by any
means but it's made a big difference in
my life
uh on how i handled my life it's it's
probably
given me the opportunity to be married
for 44 years it's just given me
opportunities to uh be better in my life
and
and i you know i i want to thank my
sister for that you know it's uh
and i think my family was ready to make
a split
because of that incident they're blaming
each other and i think that
uh i was able to help but more than that
they really liked each other but they
didn't really know it at the time
until i got out of the house two years
later
it probably was going on for a couple
years until i moved on and went to
college
then they found out they really liked
each other when they were alone
and it worked out pretty good but i
think them
being able to follow me not just through
college and the olympics and worlds but
my coaching
so it's the same the same success and
factor
you know of excitement and and all those
things gave them a real purpose
and uh it gave my four daughters it gave
my wife
uh you know a real purpose to be able to
be close
to all these champions and championships
and
and and now it's because now it's like
there's a family of 22
and they're all interested in what what
we're interested in and it's going good
knock on wood
but you know it's something that when
all of a sudden you got too much time in
your hands and you're not doing
accomplishing much
that things probably you know get off
get off track
you